das ist eine Videoantwort
ja ich habe mich gefragt wegen dem
Bericht was kam frage ich mich voller
Mut wird es dennoch gut ich weiß ja
nicht ganz genau was ich davon halten
soll ob du es noch mal schaffst oder
eben nicht ja oh ja ich würde es gerne
nicht mehr wissen
du bist oder einen anderen verschiebst
diese Phase ist ja zu Wahrheit du
brauchst einen neuen Plan vielleicht mit
Stern zusammen
ja ich habe mich gefragt wegen dem
Gerücht dass du 2011 noch mal antreten
sollst
aber ich weiß nicht ob das so gut ist
würdest du es machen oder hast du
vielleicht schon vor es ist geplant
machst es mit Steffen zusammen oder halt
doch alleine wie ist das so oder
vielleicht geheim also sag einfach mal
deine Meinung denn Lena you locks
erstmal finde ich total süß aussiehst
ich weiß ich würde dich jetzt so auf 14
schätzen ich hoffe dass es richtig
sehr sehr toll gemacht
so was finde ich immer voll super ich
höre ich höre sowas sehr gerne ja an dem
Gerücht was gar kein Gerücht ist sondern
ein feststehender Begriff quasi der
Eurovision Song Contest 2011 mit mir
stimmt
wir haben uns dazu entschieden wir sage
ich weil ich jetzt von Stefan und mir
Rede dass wir das noch mal machen ähm
und ich mache das weil ich dazu Bock
habe noch mal ich fand es total toll und
es hat mir unglaublich viel Spaß gemacht
und ähm deswegen will ich's noch mal
machen jetzt habe ich aber jetzt muss
ich aber aufstoßen
unangenehm ja und jetzt will ich es
einfach noch mal machen ohne gerülpse